the Waters of Calais where so many
migrant Journeys begin and where the
controversy of cross-channel migration
has created such turbulence
oh today a very different Journey the
Home Secretary in Paris to sign a deal
with her French counterpart
that should mean more collaboration more
patrols and more money going from
Britain to France all of this at a time
when the number of Migrant Crossings is
growing dramatically
arriving at the G20 meeting in Indonesia
the Prime Minister welcomed the deal
saying it was a priority to limit
migration now I'm confident that we can
get the numbers down but I also want to
be honest with people that it isn't a
single thing that will magically solve
this we can't do it overnight but people
should be absolutely reassured that this
is a top priority for me I'm gripping it
and as I've said in in the time that
I've been prime minister you're already
starting to see some progress with this
deal with the French but that's just the
start there's lots more that we need to
do
and this is what we saw on the Northern
French beaches over the weekend
just off the shore people Smugglers with
a new tactic sitting in their dinghies
and waiting for their customers to come
to them
on the sand but ordered to stay out of
the sea police officers trying to stop
anyone from entering the water
but evading them dozens of people who
run into the channel and then clambered
aboard the boat and set off towards
Britain
today the patrol Boats were out again
there is already a very visible presence
on and around these beaches to try to
stop people crossing the channel but the
numbers arriving in Britain on small
boats has just kept Rising so the
question is whether this new deal will
really make any difference
caught in the middle is Cali once an
upmarket Resort that is now indelibly
linked with migration and controversy
the mayor thinks Britain seems to offer
an easy life for migrants and that her
Town suffers as a result
there'll be more and more agreements in
the future but if the root of the
problem isn't dealt with it won't change
and that's to prevent the flow of
migrants the UK must become less
appealing and it just won't do that
what we're doing here is Britain's Dirty
Work
the life of a migrant here is a
miserable one it's cold and you're
shunned but what unites all these people
is a desire to leave and to get to
Britain and that dream won't change
Adam Parsons Sky News Calais